[Musique]
mon numéro était le 8 7 8 1 4 6 ils ne
m'ont jamais tatoué car ils m'ont
transféré dans un autre camp à 95 en
tête bourgueil d'origine hongroise est
un survivant de l'holocauste
c'était en 1944 l'armée allemande occupe
la hongrie et son village natal saros
patins
il est envoyé dans un ghetto juif dans
une ville proche puis déporté à
auschwitz avec sa famille
après trois jours à bord d'un train à
bétail allons de la hongrie à la pologne
le train s'arrête en plat ni au lever du
jour
il était face à des soldats allemands
à sunrise à gâteau j'ai survécu au
ghetto à cinq camps de concentration une
marche de la mort un train de la mort et
je suis encore là il se souvient de
cette journée à auschwitz la journée de
la sélection effectué aucun vol 120 ce
qui pouvait travailler
d'un côté femmes enfants et personnes
âgées de l'eau
[Musique]
ma soeur qui n'avait que 13 ans étaient
envoyés du mauvais côté celui des
chambres à gaz et ma mère a voulu la
suivre et moi nous nous sommes retrouvés
du bon côté on a dû se déshabiller ils
nous ont rasé de la tête aux pieds et
désinfectés à la fin on portait
l'uniforme rayé leur premier repas le
lendemain était une soupe qu'ils
devaient partager à 6 ils ne voulaient
pas nous donner deux cuillères parce que
les juifs qui est il ne valait pas mieux
que les chiens on avait tellement faim
qu'on a allongé comme des chiens elle
met ne veulent ramener un homme médaille
d'or
[Musique]
dix logements introduction to à
auschwitz
[Musique]
un cauchemar qui aura duré un an mais
qui le marquera toute sa vie séparé de
son père il passera d'un camp à un autre
d'un enfer à l'autre il va du ghetto
juif en hongrie au camp de concentration
d'auschwitz puis au ghetto de varsovie à
une marche de la mort vers l'allemagne
au camp de concentration de dachau aux
camps de travaux forcés de mühldorf
imiter le gars en allemagne notre
travail était de transporter des sacs de
ciment des wagons aux machines si tu
tombes et on ne sortait pas si mal
les ss recruter de jeunes hommes à
travers l'europe leur donner un bel
uniforme de la nourriture il leur disait
qu'il pouvait tuer autant de juifs
qu'ils voulaient
destin on était 120 ils nous ont poussés
dans un train qui peut aller dans une
mine abandonnée rempli d'explosifs il
avait juste à pousser le train vers la
mine 3500 juifs seraient dessus et il se
souvient de cette journée de libération
heureusement l'armée russe est arrivé
j'ai détesté le reste du monde parce
qu'ils n'ont rien fait car ce qui le
choque rats toujours c'est le silence
des nations lorsqu en 1938 le président
américain roosevelt convoque 30 pays au
bord du lac léman pour résoudre la
fameuse question juive
il a dit aux nations hitler ne veut pas
de juifs
combien allez vous en prendre il y a eu
un silence assourdissant
ni le canada ni les états unis personne
ne voulait déjà hitler y avait une
opportunité
il est arrivé avec la solution finale je
vais tous les tuer il est parvenu en
illuminé 6 millions les manades
plusieurs mois après sa libération ted
belga retrouve son père dans sa maison
natale hongrie mais il ne veut plus
rester en europe
en 1947 le canada change sa politique de
non soumis aucun c'est encore trop et
ouvre la porte à 1000 jeunes juifs le
jeune hongrois prend alors la route de
l'exil et s'installe à montréal
sunrise est neurologue cost survivra le
low cost venait avec deux obligations
d'abord assurer la continuité du peuple
juif je me suis marié en 1954
j'ai deux enfants six petits enfants et
quatre arrière petits enfants
[Musique]
la seconde obligations ne pas laisser le
monde
oubliez le cos
gâteau il raconte son histoire depuis 40
ans veuve depuis 2001 c'est avec sa
fille aînée qui liera au 75e
anniversaire de la libération
d'auschwitz
je ne suis pas la seule à y aller dit
elle y aura mon frère ses deux fils ma
fille nerfs pour ted bollgard sa famille
sera sa plus belle revanche contre
hitler notre mémoire et leur seule tombe
dans les grès plus tard il a été appelé
à témoigner contre l'officier ss oscar
groening le comptable d'auschwitz il
avait 93 ans on ne regardait jamais les
ss dans les yeux pour regarder leurs
mains pour voir ses saveurs et volver un
bâton ou un fouet aux rup
il ne l'a pas reconnu lors de ces
commémorations à auschwitz il retrouvera
une amie d'enfance qu'il avait perdu de
vue mon amour de jeunesse et en israël
elle vient à autre chose son mari est
mort je l'appelle à tous les mercredis
vannetais morning car malgré tout la vie
continue
[Musique]